i'm stuart varney i'm harris faulkner
i'm brian kilmeade and this is the fox
news rundown
friday april 8 2022 i'm chris foster the
midterm election is seven months from
today most people think the country is
on the wrong track and that the economy
is weak
so you know that's a pretty toxic brew
here that can make for a tornado against
the democrats unless something changes
i'm jessica rosenthal russia's war and
ukraine has european countries on alert
as more talk of their own military
defense and even joining nato but what
will that mean for us and our future
engagement on the continent you now have
the effect of traditionally neutral
countries like finland and sweden saying
we don't want to be alone anymore
let's join nato they're not 100 there
yet but the train is leaving the station
and i'm ben dominic i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
president biden's approval rating in
most polls in the high 30s low 40s not
what democrats want to see trying to
keep control of congress in the midterm
elections the president says his
policies are working it's been a long
tough stretch but americans are back to
work our economy has gone from being on
the mend to being on the move but
inflation has more than eaten into those
gains for most americans and the
president's popularity on the economy
for example is at 35 percent in the
latest harris poll down from 61 when he
took office house minority leader kevin
mccarthy tells fox's sean hannity
republicans will show why they should be
in the majority we're going to make
america stronger again around the world
this is just the start we'll have this
rolled out to the american public you'll
see our policies the opposition party
usually picks up seats in midterm
elections when you look at the polling
data now
unless something is done that
significantly reverses what we're seeing
you're looking at a wave election mark
pan's a former advisor and campaign
strategist for bill and hillary clinton
he's founder and ceo of the marketing
and communications company stagwell inc
and chairman of the harris poll and the
thing that you
know about wave elections is you do all
these calculations
and the wave washes you out it tends to
be bigger than you think it's going to
be because 20 30 percent of people
showing up for the polls they don't care
who the candidate is
they're there to express anger about the
inns and they want them out
um generic horse race right now favoring
republicans 53 to 47 how does that
translate this year into seats flipping
have you done that math
um i haven't done that math because that
question you know
has never really been a totally accurate
question
oftentimes when it would show three or
four points for the democrats it would
come out about about equally if it
really was a six-point spread in favor
of the republicans
uh that that really could be kind of a
50-seat you know swing i mean a lot of
people don't think that there's a
50-seat swing because they think that
gerrymandering has made so many of the
districts harder to reach and outside of
swing but uh
but but something like a six-point edge
would really be a wipeout of the of the
democrats a lot of people voted for
democrats and voted for president biden
last time because they didn't like
donald trump anymore donald trump is now
no longer on the ballot um
young democrats may be more likely i
assume to stay home
not 50 of democrats i mean republicans
approve of their party even fewer
democrats approve their party does that
suggest low turnout
uh we've really seen historically high
turnouts now that voting has become
fundamentally easier and that there's so
many mail ballots floating around
and we've seen politics become
uh you know if you if i always used to
say that you know there's basically
there's sports and there's entertainment
and
politics and politics has taken on kind
of a nature in our culture that's i
think so much stronger and higher both
in terms of voting and turnout so i i i
expect turnout to be lower than the
presidential but again i think for a
midterm
it's going to be a higher turnout
primary more people are just involved in
politics in the political system and
there's going to be a lot of money spent
by democrats and republicans here you
know in the end game
uh important issue of issues to voters
this time the the kitchen table stuff as
we call it inflation economy jobs
immigration coveted health care and none
of it president biden is above water as
far as approval goes
well i mean that is the that's the
that's the problem right the problem is
that it's quite clear
that that the the president is uh
disfavored you know by a majority of the
american public and the way he is
carrying out the job of the economy
the foreign affairs immigration crime
even the even the virus where he had the
70 ratings
is below 50 so on issue after issue
right the president and the democratic
administration are below 50 and
most people think the country's on the
wrong track and that the economy is weak
so you know that's a pretty toxic brew
here that can make for a tornado against
the democrats unless something changes
yeah um former president obama said the
other day that look it's not a lost
cause
democrats have accomplished more than
they're getting across and they're just
doing a bad job of selling stuff but in
the end isn't that you know perception's
reality
uh well perception is reality in
politics but also reality is reality
okay their inflation is high uh i think
that the problem the administration is
not of messaging right the russians did
invade so deterrence didn't work
inflation is the highest in 40 years the
crossings in the border are in the in
the millions right crime is up in
virtually every major city so i
strongly disagree with that because
believing that it's just a messaging is
what allows people to just punt and say
oh don't worry we'll have better
messaging we'll have money we'll get out
our message don't change policy no
policy here is not working
i know it's not fair to blame i don't
know somebody running for congress in
whatever state they have nothing to do
with what's happening in the border they
have nothing to do with inflation they
have nothing to do with gas prices but
them's the brakes right i mean what
happens especially in these midterm
elections is that whoever's in power
is going to drag down members of their
party down the ticket
well in midterm elections a lot of low
information voters as you point out
classically didn't vote at all
so that a higher proportion of the
voters would be voters who really
understood the candidates
knew them had some sense of how their
representative was doing in their state
or district
and the elections would be more
localized
given the communication system we have
the higher
ability and emphasis on stimulating more
people to to turn out
a greater percentage of the voters are
these voters who don't care who the
candidates are
and are there to express hey i'm a
democrat i want to strengthen the
democratic party or no i'm mad at the
democrats or i'm a republican now
and and they don't care they don't
follow the race and they don't follow
all the details of who's a better
representative and
that is the key component of a wave
election
that that an individual
a candidate or representative who's done
a good job with the district gets so
frustrated
we're about two years and seven months
away from the next presidential election
um in a horse race democrats say that
you know joe biden's the favorite but
only a third 34 percent say that they
that they support him that seems
remarkably low
well that is an
unprecedentedly low
polling figure for a sitting president
when i ask a democratic primary i've
never seen it like that that means
there's no real expectation among
democrats that joe biden is going to be
the nominee going forward they either
think he hasn't done a good enough job
or he's too old that they really see him
as a one-term president and would be
really shocked if he didn't
sometime in the next year he's not going
to want to make himself a lame duck
prematurely
pull out of the next presidential race
unless there's an unbelievable
turnaround here in his administration
the likes of which we have not seen
since i worked with president clinton
who came out in the midterms
and really you know battled his way to a
second term
speaking of former president clinton if
president biden steps down there's no
real clear front runner
kamala harris doesn't have a ton of
support nationally um i
hillary clinton's there too but i you
know i don't know what's going to happen
with her i doubt she would run again
right and
so is there is there an opportunity for
somebody like a bill clinton to bubble
up out of nowhere out of one of the
states maybe some sort of moderate
democrat and uh and climb ahead of the
pack
well bill clinton himself we know can't
do that but
there is something of a power vacuum you
know again
when hillary started out second time she
was at 45
or
uh even the first time when al gore
was vice president he was at 65 percent
of the democratic electorate to have
someone who's sitting vice president
only at 23 is weak
on a countervailing basis though the
history is hubert humphrey alcorn
you name it walter mondale vice
presidents get the nomination right and
they part of the reason is post the
midterms she'll probably control the
party machinery
uh and if she controls all the machinery
and and she might even
wind up president here you never know
what's going to happen with all this
hunter bite and stuff floating around
and
and so
so i you know if i were like betting i
think she'll wind up the democratic
nominee one way or the other that's my
guess i think she has a pretty high
probability
and i don't see anyone right now you
know being able to put a strong
challenge even if hillary clinton is
obviously sniffing around the edges well
then we get a look at the other uh
co-star of the last presidential
election donald trump is hinting he's
going to run again i guess nobody really
really knows he said um that he i don't
know if it was shot across the bow but
he said geez i can't i can't imagine
that uh florida governor ron desantis
would want to run against me i don't see
that mike pence would run against me or
mike pompeo would run against me um he's
the clear favorite right
uh yes he's definitely the clearer
favorite
he has a strong vote in the republican
primary but hey george bush i'm sorry
jeb bush was the strong favorite when
donald trump got in
so we're but you know people who are the
challengers become the incumbents and
have all this baggage with them that's
really quite different from the time
that they were the surprise challenger
so could donald trump get in as the
front runner absolutely could there be a
surprise challenger or even a not so
surprised challenger absolutely could
people be looking to go forward rather
than back
i wouldn't count his renomination as any
kind of certainty uh in in this
environment this isn't polled but i was
talking to tom bevin from your real
clear politics not long ago he said that
his gut
is that we're going to get a whole new
cast of characters that it's not going
to be trump and it's not going to be
biden that it's going to be a whole new
thing that that people will want to look
forward in 2024. i i think if the
american voter round up with trump
versus clinton again they would get
really frustrated about what happened
and i think you'd see a third candidate
evolve i think unless these parties
evolve to a new set of candidates i
wouldn't be surprised
to see uh joe manchin or others run as
an independent candidacy here and
possibly
even win
mark pence ceo of stagwell inc harris
poll chairman mark good to talk to you
again thank you thank you
[Music]
this is ben dominic with your fox news
commentary coming up
our military leadership is warning of a
protracted russian war in ukraine that
could last for years and european
countries some more than others are
highly aware of their proximity to
russia as more of them are now talking
about joining nato secretary of state
anthony blinken said after meeting with
nato counterparts in brussels thursday a
hallmark of everything that we've been
doing
in the months leading up to russia's
aggression against ukraine and in the
time since has been
our
extraordinary collaboration coordination
consultation
adding that for the first time ever
foreign ministers from indo-pacific
allies australia japan and korea
participated in a nato ministers meeting
and representatives from georgia finland
sweden and ukraine took part as well
earlier this week defense secretary
lloyd austin told the house armed
services committee that what future help
looks like for our nato allies even
non-nato allies may shift a lot nato is
going through a process right now to
really kind of
assess how the we expect that the
security architecture in the region uh
is going to change for the foreseeable
future or has changed for the
foreseeable future
uh but with that in mind then you know
we'll look to work with with nato to
if nato deems that it's appropriate to
to change its footprint
then certainly we'll be a part of that
russia was suspended from the u.n human
rights council thursday with 93 votes
but 24 countries voted against the
suspension and 58 countries abstained
the u.n ambassador to china which voted
against the suspension said such a hasty
move which forces countries to choose
sides will aggravate the division among
member states and intensify the
confrontation between the parties
concerned it is like adding fuel to the
fire he said it can appear rather binary
kurt volcker is former u.s ambassador to
nato and distinguished fellow at the
center for european policy analysis
putin has gone all out and made himself
an international pariah
he has launched an unprovoked aggression
against a sovereign neighboring state he
has engaged in indiscriminate attacks
against civilians and population centers
he has launched
10 million people out of their homes
three to four million of them in
neighboring countries six million or so
displaced within ukraine so he has gone
all out and making himself and making
russia a global pariah
this has rallied the world around
ukraine and its cause ukraine is a
sovereign state its people are striving
to build a modern country they are
suffering unspeakable uh brutality and
so everyone is trying to help them so
yes in that sense
it is it has become a little black and
white in a moral sense
the second thing i would say about this
though is that
already i think we can say that russia
has lost
and that ukraine ultimately will win
and the question now is how this all
plays out
um russia
cannot take over ukraine it cannot take
ukrainian territory and hold it
the ukrainians have put up fierce
resistance they have killed thousands of
people of russian soldiers estimates are
as much as a third of russia's combat
capability has been destroyed now in
this war
and then on top of this you have the
economic sanctions that the u.s and the
eu have imposed so russia is now
effectively driving itself into the
ground as a result of this war
and then
the rest of the world is really stepping
up to help ukraine
you just said that vladimir putin has
made russia and himself a pariah that
russia has lost we've heard that before
but
when russia was suspended from the human
rights council thursday there were still
24 votes against the suspension and 58
abstentions so russia is not without its
supporters and those abstentions are
certainly you know noteworthy
countries like brazil and india
do russian friends or those abstainers
matter and how much
i don't think it matters a lot to be
honest
first off
i think we have to look at dependencies
many countries have gotten themselves
into a position of dependence on russia
germany of course recently and now
they're struggling to get out of that
and struggling to figure out how to shut
off russian gas
india likewise they they got off iranian
uh oil and gas and now they're addicted
to russian oil and gas but that doesn't
mean that india is siding with russia in
the war they just want to stay out of it
and i think we have to look at this
through a couple of lenses at the same
time as we just said there is kind of a
black and white right and wrong moral
case here russia being an aggressor
russia killing civilians
nobody's attacking russia no one's
killing russian civilians and that makes
this a very clear moral case that's on
the one side
on the other side though countries are
looking at how does this end
what happens afterwards how do we manage
our own interests and
the west
which is involved in in this deeply it's
a ukraine is a european country and they
are supporting ukraine's right to
sovereignty independence
and protecting itself but you know if
you're in africa or if you're in india
or if you're in you know south america
you're looking at this as very far away
very unfortunate we sympathize with
ukrainians
but we don't really want to get dragged
into this
so again that doesn't mean sympathy with
russia that just means these countries
are calculating their own interest and
staying quiet
as you noted secretary of state blinken
um said there's a growing coalition of
countries with with ukraine and against
russia we know finland even sweden
are expressing more support for joining
nato themselves although sweden
apparently based on polling isn't over
that 50 mark
what might happen with
nato and europe you know what might
things look like in a year maybe five
years especially if our military
leadership is right and this war could
last for years
yeah so unfortunately our military
leadership has been long at most points
in this crisis uh calculating that
russia would roll over kiev within three
days that ukrainians would not mount a
effective defense that they can't
integrate western arms
all of this wrong and i think they're
wrong on the length of the war as well
this is not going to be years what we're
looking at is weeks to months
where russia has had a significant blow
to its armed forces it is struggling to
regroup
and the more help we can give to ukraine
right now when they have momentum the
more this will disrupt russia's ability
to regroup and retake territory
ultimately i don't believe that russia
can withstand a military defeat and an
economic collapse at the same time the
outlines of this are clear
russia emerges from this weakened
economically politically and militarily
ukraine survives as a sovereign and
independent european state
and the west is now clearly on ukraine's
side
talking about eu membership providing
massive reconstruction funds to rebuild
the country so this fundamentally
transforms the map from what we were
looking at just three months ago yeah
talk to me more broadly though about
europe and nato our our alliances i mean
we're talking now
about permanent bases in eastern europe
you know that's been a subject of
conversation over the past couple of
weeks before house armed services
committee meetings um what do you
envision i mean let's say this does only
last you know weeks or months
would it still dramatically change
how nato functions how europe functions
yes i think so so let's look at nato
nato has done a good job
in affirming the article 5 security
guarantee for all members
and backing that up with deployment of
forces to central and east european
member states to demonstrate to russia
that if there is an attack on any of
them there will be a military response
that's very good i think we have to be
pleased with how nato has handled this a
lot of unity a lot of coming together
second you have you now have the effect
as you indicated of traditionally
neutral countries like finland and
sweden saying
we don't want to be alone anymore
let's join nato they're not 100 there
yet but the train is leaving the station
then you have the european union
three months ago i was in brussels and
everyone talked about ukraine as a
challenge
i was there last week and everyone
talked about ukraine as a european
country that we have to help
so the mentality has shifted
fundamentally in ukraine's favor they
see ukraine ultimately as a part of
europe
so then when you talk about the future
of ukraine you're looking at a european
country
an independent sovereign state
a future member of the eu
and gaining security guarantees from
states in europe if not from nato itself
that's still to be determined
it changes the landscape completely uh
none of no more of this well we have to
work with russia
russia is now left out as a pariah state
until
putin is gone and until their forces are
out of ukraine
our military leadership said this week
that putin was undeterrable that he
could have only been deterred with like
essentially boots on the ground
but that was a decision obviously that
we decided against
so then this was never really going to
be stopped was it
yeah so this is what in washington we
call a
washington monument argument
where you can't ever cut the budget
because then there would be no funds to
maintain the washington monument
and it's like well
we could maintain the washington
monument decide to not spend money on
something else
and so this is that kind of argument
where anything we did
to deter vladimir putin would mean boots
on the ground u.s military engagement
world war three therefore you can't do
it
and i don't buy that at all i think
there are many things that we could have
done
earlier and more decisively that would
have indicated vladimir putin that he
would get into exactly the scenario that
he's in now
that there would be
decisive military support for ukraine
there would be devastating sanctions we
could have given him very clear and
stern warnings that we will engage we
will support ukraine we didn't do any of
those things
and i accept
the judgment of our political leadership
that we didn't want to have u.s forces
directly engaged with russian forces but
there are so many things below that
threshold that we could have done that
could have made a difference
finally there has been a lot of talk
about china and taiwan
vis-a-vis ukraine
and what lessons can be applied from
that as we prepare for xi jinping to
actually go after taiwan i know
secretary austin said this week we can't
really compare ukraine and taiwan but
some members of congress are expressing
real concern like do we need to arm
taiwan in a certain way with ukraine
we've been laser focused you know on
giving defensive not offensive weapons
but
what could we do to deter china from
taiwan and
why wouldn't the results of invading
ukraine
be a deterrent like china doesn't want
similar economic sanctions china doesn't
want to deal with similar punishments
right the best thing we can do
to deter china on engaging military
against taiwan is to make sure that
ukraine succeeds if russia a much bigger
military power
with nuclear weapons and with superior
you know finances and intelligence and
so forth can attack a country like
ukraine which is weaker than taiwan
and ukraine wins
what better signal is there to china
that taiwan is not going to be so easy
and moreover taiwan will fight as well
the west will help taiwan we should make
that clear and we should take steps now
to demonstrate that as we could have
done with ukraine
and yes ukraine is being destroyed but
at the end of that there will be a
massive support to rebuild ukraine
none of this is what china wants to see
if it's thinking about an easy win in
taiwan
kurt volcker thank you so much for your
time
my pleasure thanks for the time
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the nation's oldest active park ranger
is hanging up her smokey hat at the age
of 100.
betty reed saskin retired after more
than 15 years at the rosie the riveter
world war ii homefront national
historical park in richmond california
according to the national park service
she led tours at the park and museum
honoring the women who worked in
factories during wartime and shared her
own experience as a black woman during
the conflict she worked for the u.s air
force in 1942
but quit after learning that quote she
was employed only because her superiors
believed she was white according to a
park service biography
she won a temporary park service
position at the age of 84 and became a
permanent park service employee in 2011.
she celebrated her 100th birthday last
september saskan was born betty
charbonnet in detroit in 1921 but
recalled surviving the devastating great
mississippi flood of 1927 while living
with her creole family in new orleans
the biography goes on to say that her
family then moved to oakland california
and saskin remained in the san francisco
bay area in 1945 she and her first
husband founded one of the first
black-owned record stores in the area
she was also a civil rights activist and
took part in meetings to develop a
general management plan for the home
front park she's received several honors
including being named california woman
of the year in 1995.
in 2015 she received a presidential coin
from president obama after she lit the
national christmas tree at the white
house saskin was also honored with entry
into the congressional record glamour
magazine named her woman of the year in
2018.
and in honor of her 100th birthday in
september of 2021 a middle school in the
bay area was renamed in her honor she
said in a statement giving shape to a
new national park has been exciting and
fulfilling it has proven to bring
meaning to my final years
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind according to
conventional wisdom america's modern
history regarding foreign policy and
national security has gone through
periods of significant upheaval we've
been a nation that desired retreat from
the world stage in the wake of vietnam
that engaged the power of market forces
to try to reform communist china in the
post-cold war era and was bent on wars
with utopian visions of recreating the
middle east in our democratic image
after 9 11. but from another more
rational perspective america's foreign
policy has been through all this time
remarkably consistent a jacksonian bent
toward our security interests with the
will and capability to reach out to
destroy our enemies at any time and
against wars of conquest or goals that
seem out of touch with reality it was
this attitude of permanent jacksonianism
that donald trump tapped into as a
candidate for the presidency he ran not
against all wars but against dumb wars
not as a dove but as someone who wanted
the ability to strike back against
america's enemies with the greatest
possible might he stressed the need for
other nations to live up to their
obligations via nato and other security
commitments in his frame america was
done fighting the battles of others for
them on the backs of american taxpayers
but if you proved you were willing to
fight for yourselves you would receive
the tools to do so and to be backed by
the americans meant you would be backed
to the fullest
so it should surprise no one that within
short order after vladimir putin's
advanced westward the former president
begins sounding increasingly hawkish
notes in favor of the ukrainian forces
who put up a courageous fight against
the invaders trump called for tougher
sanctions heavier weapons and more
advanced fighters to be delivered on
ukraine's behalf a reminder that the
media concocted fiction about his
relationship with russia ignored so much
of his actual policy instincts and the
republican party stands with him with
overwhelming numbers suggesting we ought
to do more to help the ukrainians an
overwhelming majority support from
republicans for president zielinski
republicans are where the former
president is and he is with them
all this serves to make a recent letter
from non-interventionists organized in
the auspices of sorabamari's new
publication compact extremely odd as a
major foray for the new publication into
the realm of foreign policy the signers
whose ranks include integralist thinkers
leftists and a cross-section of others
pledged their names to a letter that
seems to be operating in a fantasyland
the letter wars repeatedly against
escalation apparently defined as a path
toward world war three but despite the
intemperate ramblings of the current
occupant of the oval office there is no
support whatsoever in the congress or
the country for a war of regime change
in russia there is not even any
significant support for a no-fly zone
except perhaps and as part of a
negotiated peace and the only way such a
negotiation for peace can take place as
if russia is truly on its heels a
circumstance that can only be achieved
if the ukrainians have the heavy weapons
and anti-air capability they have been
asking for in the past month something
the signers of the letter apparently
view as an escalatory act in itself is
it the belief of these signatories that
the world and ukraine would be better
off if the ukrainians would just lose
faster there is currently a large
discussion about the future of a
conservative's understanding of what it
means to adopt an america first foreign
policy as with so many slogans this one
is ripe for interpretation and
reinterpretation but one thing an
america first policy cannot be and will
not be is something at odds with the
overwhelming interests of the american
people and supporting our friends
opposing our adversaries and maintaining
america's stature in the world the
american people have very clearly picked
a side in this conflict casting aside
any past illusions of a productive
relationship with vladimir putin a view
shared by our allies in the west and
beyond an open letter based on such
fantastical assumptions about the nature
of the current conflict is unlikely to
change the minds that matter nor should
it
i'm ben dominic this article was
published at national review which you
can find at nationalreview.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes